- OH, THERE'S MY GIRL.
EXCUSE ME.
MISS CRUZ?
- YEAH?
- SORRY FOR BEING SO FORMAL.
IT'S JUST AN HONOR
TO MEET YOU.
I'M FRIENDS WITH ONE
OF THE ALUMNI SWIMMERS HERE,
AND I'VE BEEN ADMIRING
YOUR PHOTO IN THE YEARBOOK
FOR QUITE SOME TIME NOW.
- YOU MEAN, LIKE,
PICTURES OF ME AS A KID?
- YEAH, AND MAY I SAY
YOU STILL LOOK VERY YOUNG.
IN A GOOD WAY.
YOU STILL LOOK VERY YOUNG,
BUT CUTTING TO THE CHASE,
LIKE A GINSU,
I WAS JUST WONDERING IF MAYBE
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ACCOMPANY ME
TO A SUSHI DINNER.
I LOVE EATING SASHIMI,
BUT I WOULD RATHER EAT
SASHI-YOU.
- OOH, NOT REALLY
INTO SUSHI.
THANKS, THOUGH,
AND I'M NOT JAPANESE,
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
- YEAH.
NO, IT WAS.
SORRY, I BLEW THAT.
OH, HEY!
SO, ADAM, WHAT'S UP?
THIS IS MY GIRL, SHERRY.
THIS IS MY NINJA, ADAM.
- YOUR GIRL?
BUT THIS IS--
[R&B music]
- ♪ YOU'RE MESSING
WITH THE SAME GIRL ♪
♪ SAME GIRL
- ♪ SAME GIRL
- ♪ HOW COULD THE LOVE
OF MY LIFE ♪
♪ AND MY POTENTIAL WIFE
BE THE ♪
- ♪ THE SAME GIRL
- ♪ SAME GIRL
- ♪ JUST I CAN'T BELIEVE
- BREAK THE GRIP!
BREAK THE GRIP!
[shouts]
- OKAY.
- OW!
ADAM, YOU'RE HURTING ME!
OKAY?
NOT IN FRONT OF MY GIRL.
- YOUR GIRL?
MORE LIKE MY GIRL.
I'M THE MACAULAY CULKIN
OF THIS SITUATION.
- WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
- I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE MOVIE MY GIRL!
WITH THE LITTLE GIRL,
LOVES MACAULAY CULKIN
SO MUCH SHE GETS STINGED
BY A TON OF BEES AND DIES.
- I THOUGHT HE DIED.
- I DON'T KNOW!
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE MOVIE
IN A LONG TIME!
- IT'S BESIDES THE POINT, MAN.
I THOUGHT YOU TOLD ME THAT YOUR
CHICK WAS A BLACK GIRL, DUDE.
- YEAH, AND THAT GIRL
IS SUPER BLACK.
SHE'S A SUPER BLACK BEAUTY.
AND YOU SAID YOUR GIRL
WAS ASIAN,
AND THAT IS NOW
WHAT SHE LOOKS LIKE.
- SHE IS--HEY, SHERRY?
- SHERRY?
- WHAT ARE YOU?
- EXCUSE ME?
- YOUR ETHNICITY.
- YEAH, YOUR BACKGROUND.
LIKE, YOUR GENETIC BUILDUP.
- JESUS, FILIPINO.
- HA, THAT'S ASIAN!